le bilan des piétons morts sur les
routes du Québec est alarmant pour
monter à 2007 pour voir un aussi pire
bilan pour les piétons au Québec selon
le dernier bilan routier de la salle à
un an 392 personnes sont mortes sur les
routes du Québec 79 d'entre elles sont
des piétons une hausse de 23% par
rapport à la moyenne des 5 dernières
années derrière c'est triste chiffres
des visages comme celui de la petite
Maria frappée par une voiture sur le
chemin de l'école en décembre pour
sécuriser les piétons ce serait d'aller
vers une culture ou le piéton a toujours
priorité le piéton toujours raison plus
autopomalistes ralentissent
mais il y a toujours beaucoup de travail
à faire un conducteur sur deux ne
respecte toujours pas les limites de
vitesse selon l'Association des
Directeurs de police du Québec dans les
zones de 30 km/h par exemple
71% des automobilistes dépassent la
limite et 24% à l'excès de même par plus
de 10 km/h les brigadiers sont souvent
les premiers témoins de ces écarts de
conduite des fois on est confronté à des
gens qui refusent carrément de s'arrêter
quand moi je suis là en train de faire
des choses extrêmement dangereux la
vitesse c'est pas c'est pas le midi
comme les matins les soirs là c'est
l'enfer ça a pas de bon sens tout le
monde est pressé le matin en plus de la
vitesse le problème c'est aussi la
taille
on a de plus en plus de vieilles de plus
en plus de pick-up camionnette le sur
nos routes lorsqu'une collision avec ce
type de véhicule là elle est
conséquences sont plus graves pour les
piétons la saison estivale apporte son
lot de défis sur les routes l'an dernier
le mois de juillet a été le plus
meurtrier par la sensibilisation les
policiers espèrent sauver des vies ici
Charles Dumoulin Radio-Canada Montréal